[Music]
Taylor Swift is coming y'all I'm just
really excited singer sent fans into a
frenzy on Friday deleting her entire
social media history but what does it
all mean and breaking it down Monday she
slithered back onto social media with
this a cryptic snake video snakes shed
their skin to allow for further growth
which goes hand in hand with some of her
other clues the last three Instagram
captions before they were deleted all
featured messages about time growth and
age the final portions of those into
capsules were each 13 characters in
length of course that's Taylor's
favorite number it's gonna be so fun on
Friday when you search Taylor's name on
DirecTV it said she would appear on Good
Morning America
on August 31st flip that number 13
another strange coincidence this Katy
Perry tweet about her swish-swish video
cast Rafi Taylor's name in her bad blood
video
so we like the subtle references to
growth and time we also like all the use
of the number 13 and the idea of
disappearing and vanishing is also
interesting but only time will tell I
don't understand how you cannot fangirl
about that
[Music]
you